die berühmteste frau der welt ist tot
ihr krönungsjubiläum seien damals 277
millionen menschen mit 96 jahren ist die
queen nun verstorben die welt trauert um
sie und damit herzlich willkommen zum
viertel nach acht spezial meine gäste
heute abend sind fdp-außenpolitiker
alexander graf lambsdorff star kulissen
publizist hans ulrich jörges die
stellvertretende bild chefredakteur in
tanja may und die politik reporter
viktor wachse in cambridge studiert hat
graf lambsdorff elisabeth die zweite war
eine sehr außergewöhnliche frau was wird
von ihr am meisten in erinnerung bleiben
ich glaube dass sie es geschafft hat
eine zeit der beständigkeit herzustellen
in einer zeit radikalen wandels
großbritannien hat sich ja total
geändert in ihrer lebenszeit vom empire
zu einem ganz normalen start von einer
modischen also rein weißen nationen zu
einer total bunten nation man muss sich
ja nur mal die neue regierung angucken
die vier wichtigsten minister sind alle
nicht weiß und sie hat in dieser zeit
einen anker geboten ein anker der
verlässlichkeit ein anker der
beständigkeit deswegen ist es ja auch so
dass wir alle wir alle hier heute und
die ganze welt über die queen redet sie
ist ja nicht die einzige königin die es
auf der welt gibt aber sie ist sie war
unsere queen genauso wie die queen der
engländerin und engländer kann ja warum
ist die queen was graf lambsdorff gerade
angesprochen eine so besonders weil hat
natürlich recht es gibt ja nicht nur die
eine königin
ich denke die königin oder die queen hat
es geschafft von tag eins an ihrer
regentschaft sie hat ja ihr leben
komplett der krone untergeordnet und das
hat man ja jetzt auch gesehen bis zum
letzten atemzug wirklich hat sie ihren
dienst getan sie war sie hat noch vor
zwei tagen ja die britische die neue
britische premierministerin eingeführt
im urlaub in schottland hatte sie
empfangen und jetzt ist sie tot und sie
hat wirklich bis zur letzten minute
gezeigt ja was es bedeutet königin zu
sein hat dem alles untergeordnet selbst
ihre große liebe für den philipp ihre
kinder ihre familie eben alles viktor
weiß wird nur besser heute auch schon
den ganzen tag im chat verläufen mit
deinen wünschen denn dein kommilitonen
aus england und ein freund vor ort wie
sehr trauert england um ihre königin ich
glaube trauen ist vielleicht gar nicht
mehr das richtige wort sondern da ist
was zerbrochen was wie wo das wort
trauer gar nicht dem gerecht wird etwas
zerbrochen was man nie wieder bringen
kann etwas undenkbares und das witzig
was ich heute festgestellt habe durch
meine englischen freundeskreise war wie
sehr gerade die junge generation die
leute unter 30 völlig fertig waren und
nicht wussten wo sie hin sollen denn die
haben ihr ganzes leben unter der queen
gehabt und irgendwie england ist durch
seine wilde zeit gegangen brave corona
wir hatten sonderwegs war alles anfahren
sind jetzt ist das land der riesen
inflation riesen krisen und die queen
war immer da sie was stabil und jetzt
ist sie weg und kann es nachvollziehen
ich habe auch getraut muss ich sagen ich
habe eine besondere beziehung zu
großbritannien ich habe lange für
reuters gearbeitet habe viele englische
freunde mein bester ist immer noch in
london er war früher chefredakteur von
reuters dem habe ich gleich kontrolliert
und ich habe mir dann ein whisky ein
geschenk den habe ich ob sie gehoben zu
hause
ich kann das gut verstehen für mich war
die frau kulturell immer eine figur aus
den 60er jahren immer 60 er jahre die
kleidung was sie was sie getan hat was
sie gesagt hat wie sie sich bewegt hat
die tradition die sie ausgestrahlt hat
die war für mich keine 70er 80er 90er
jahre figur schon gar keine nach der
jahrtausendwende und ich glaube dass sie
das was sie zusammengehalten hat jetzt
auch zur fallen dort in den nächsten
jahren das ist für großbritannien sehr
schmerzlich ich glaube zunächst mal dass
der kommerz zerfällt also die der
britische könig oder die königin sind ja
staatsoberhaupt eine ganze reihe von
ländern australien kanada noch eine
ganze reihe anderer länder in kanada in
australien hat schon eine diskussion
gegeben dass das zu ende sein muss wenn
die queen mal nicht mehr da ist und
jetzt unter prinz nämlich prinz sondern
king charles wird das zu ende gehen
vielleicht eine frage von ein zwei
jahren und dann bin ich mal gespannt im
oktober 223 soll es wieder eine
volksbefragung in schottland geben über
die unabhängigkeit obwohl king charles
in seiner jugend in schottland auf einem
internat war und immer eine beziehung zu
dem land hatte und gerne im schottenrock
rumlaufen ist glaube ich nicht dass er
das zusammenhält kann die mir vorstellen
dass die unabhängigkeitsbewegung dort
befördert wird durch den wechsel und wir
sehen ja im übrigen wenn wir das
verallgemeinern auf uns beziehen unsere
lebensverhältnisse wie sehen wir die
welt der tod dieser frau ist ein symbol
für den zerfall der lebens und
machtverhältnisse wie wir sie kennen wir
sehen das in der ukraine im verhältnis
zu russland wir werden wieder einen
eisernen vorhang kriegen und
wahrscheinlich über jahrzehnte hinweg
sehr schwierige verhältnisse hier und
was diese frau in großbritannien
überstrahlt hat und was hier bei uns
immer weniger zu überstrahlen ist weil
solche figuren gibt es bei uns nicht
mehr es für mich das hauptthema dieser
zeiten staatsversagen in großbritannien
ist das gesundheitswesen so schlecht
organisiert dass sich leute die zähne
selbst zehn als sie bezahlen können
diese armut bewegung alles das wird
jetzt sichtbar werden ich würde immer
noch gerne auf die von dir angesprochene
zeitenwende eingehen und da graf
lambsdorff fragen ob er bei der these
mit gibt dass es jetzt einen schnitt
gibt und diese konstante nicht mehr zu
halten ist auch meine mitarbeiterin
meine engste mitarbeiterin seit vielen
jahren bei mir die sagte heute mein gott
das ist jetzt wirklich eine zeitenwende
und für viele menschen und ich glaube
gerade menschen in unserer generation
ohne jörges und ich
endet heute so in gewisser weise das
zwanzigste jahrhundert für elisabeth war
der erste premierminister den sie hatte
winston churchill ja das war der der
hitler besiegt hat das muss man sich mal
vorstellen man kann sich das gar nicht
klar machen was das bedeute aber das ist
ja auch so ein ergebnis noch aus der
zeit des empire aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert ob es zerbrechen wird oder
nicht ich bin nicht ganz so
pessimistisch was das ganze commonwealth
angeht weil charles einen guten ruf hat
inzwischen kanada aber hanna dann
australien wird wie kanada und
australien mögen eine ausnahme sein wie
viele länder an die den kommunen gehören
die da noch interessant sind aber dieser
diese dieser das gefühl der zeitenwende
dass das das zwanzigste jahrhundert mit
dem abschied von elisabeth jetzt auch zu
verabschieden ist endgültig ein für
allemal weil wir sind dann ist zusammen
gehalten was da die rolle dass man sagt
und das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr sie hat
in der hunde sie hat im grunde die
monarchie stabilisiert in einem
unmoralischen zeitalter 2 ein zeitalter
der republik das war eine zeitalter der
der unabhängigkeit aus britischer sich
der dekolonisierung vergessen in die
ganzen länder in afrika asien
indien bangladesch
ghana kenia als all diese länder über
die wir so reden das sind alles länder
die entstanden sind im wegbrechen von
großbritannien weil mir das ein bisschen
komplizierter wird das führt jetzt
soweit
und deswegen ist es sozusagen eine
wirkliche ja eine wirkliche zeitenwende
ein ende dieses jahrhunderts mit dem
ableben dieser und die monarchie in
großbritannien war ja mehrfach gefährdet
ernsthaft die jetzige premier ministerin
war mal diesmal gegen die monarchie
angetreten die waren anderen partei bei
den liberaldemokraten und war hat eine
kampagne gemacht für die abschaffung der
monarchie und die man lieber ernsthaft
gefährdet nach dallas tot weil diese
frau die jetzt gestorben ist so
hartherzig war das darf man nicht über
vergessen so hartherzig war dass sie
kein zeichen ihres mitgefühls gegeben
hat werden die briten
gab damals als der jänner gestorben ist
hieß es sie seien hartherzig weil sie
nicht sofort raus gegangen ist das ein
palast und nicht sofort gezeigt hat wie
sie trauert aber ich glaube dass er ein
sehr großes herz hatte und das sieht man
auch jetzt wie sie es geschafft hat
diese familie zusammenzuhalten auch
jetzt william und harry die beiden
jungen prinzen wie die sich zerstritten
haben und trotzdem sie hat es immer auch
prinz andrew die skandale display gibt
also sie hat es geschafft diese familie
zusammenzuhalten und bei der jänner war
sie zunächst ich glaube gar nicht mal
das es hartherzig von ihr war sondern
sie hat ja von anfang an gesagt
emotionen haben der öffentlichkeit
nichts verloren was ich denke was ich
fühle bleibt in den palast ich glaube
sie ab und alena verurteilt weil die ist
gestorben nachdem sie mit dodi im hotel
ritz in paris war das gehört sich nicht
bevor sie gestorben ist das war nicht
das wird er wollte sie kein umgang mehr
haben keine figuren mit dem könig aber
müssen haben sollen